and I've been tasked today with trying
to convince you that the next big
question is how do our genes make us
healthy and sick your genome is the most
important asset that you have but at the
current time we don't really know much
about what it does or how it works for
you the second point is that genes
influence all aspects of your life we
know little of the process of how they
work what the mechanisms underlying
these diseases actually are and third
point is technology is now poised to be
available to us that will allow us to
decipher our complete genomic or genetic
blueprint but really at the present time
we don't know much about what that
information means or how it will affect
your life nine out of the ten leading
causes of global death actually have a
genetic component we've reached this
inspiring moment where we can work with
single electrons with single atoms and
molecules is inconceivable that we would
not seek to make our electronic devices
work individually with these fundamental
building blocks of nature just Harrell
get a bit melodramatic as it is
inconceivable that no human would have
attempted to climb Mount Everest and I
might add just as Everest was not
conquered by someone climbing alone the
collaborative approach fostered by sea
far is essential for a challenge of this
magnitude most significantly to
tonight's to be lots of really big
questions about our world and universe
will become more answerable through
greatly increased computational capacity
science has just become completely tied
up with computers but as astonishing as
modern computers already are it's fair
to say that they still can't give much
insight into very many really big
questions this underscores my ultimate
position on why control of single
electron should be our next big question
because it's the enabling tool to unlock
a whole treasure chest of really big
answers
the brain is absolutely the best
computer in the world at a whole bunch
of tasks that we'd like to build
machines to do and we have no idea how
it works so we're just trying to figure
it out so it's not just about building
meet robots and you know cube devices
once we understand how the brain really
works I think the impact is going to be
extremely dramatic so educational
psychology are really going to be
transformed as much fun knowing how the
brain works as medicine was transformed
by really knowing how the body works in
a scientific way you know the era of
sort of pre scientific medicine was very
very crude because there was no sort of
fundamental understanding of how it
worked and so especially our
understanding and treatment of
neurological diseases memory disorders
learning disabilities both in adults and
children is going to take just an
absolutely huge step for
why do we want to look at what makes
people happy in fact it's one of the
kind of classic questions it's something
that's been of interest to philosophers
for a very long time in particular it
was something about which Aristotle
pondered a great length and it was
something that he saw is being central
to the very meaning of life a lack of
money can make you unhappy and certain
i'm sure many of us have had that
experience okay but having more money
and more and more money will not make
you more and more happy it kind of need
to kind of tops out to get a kind of
ceiling effect once you've got a certain
amount similarly the same is true for
health health is something of a
dissatisfied if you have bad health you
feel miserable but actually when you
have good health you take it for granted
okay but it's a question that we need to
get now right and that we need to start
getting right for more than just the
philosophical reasons that Aristotle was
worried about but it's one that we need
to get rides for families for the
workplace for communities and perhaps
most pressingly of all for the planet as
a whole